it's not like the gold medal that you
hold at the end is the prize who you
became to hold the gold medal is the
price it's not like everything's gonna
be fine when I hold this thing no who
you become to hold this thing that's it
we're brought to you today by Roka
unlock 20 off your order with the code
Rich Roll at roca.com
[Music]
I really want to um get into your mental
health Journey yeah you've gone through
a lot yeah
um you've come out the other side but uh
of all of my friends uh you've you've
weathered you know perhaps the most
intense uh you know experience survive
to tell the tale uh and it's really you
know it's all right
dude like I know like we I I want to go
there like do you want to go there
Absolutely I'll be happy to like so it's
really to walk me through this what's
interesting is where we're sitting right
now we're in the suburb of Sydney called
North Bondi and um we are about 215
meters which is a unit of managed
measurement the rest of the world uses
but for our you know isolationist North
American or American friends uh it's
about 900 feet no 600 feet from one of
the places that all really started to
fall fall apart
um about 20 20 something years ago uh
because like look I was I was a jumpy
kid
um I'm 49 as we're recording this
um I was a pretty jumpy kid I remember
going to
um my parents talking to psychiatrist
the age of five now what's going on with
the kid
that you go to a psychiatrist I don't
know I just remember going but they were
trying to help me best they could and
realized that whatever they were dealing
with was beyond their excuse me meaning
like hyperactive terrified and anxious
ADHD like no that stuff didn't come to
quite later it was just like four mega
mega panic attack like Ultra panic
attacks I remember like like the kind of
panic attacks um that were just so
overwhelming and um I distinctly
remember being so terrified and going to
hide under my bed
um at the age of five I think and I
couldn't
but hiding under the bed didn't make it
away because if they make it go away
because the thing that was terrifying
was in my own body I couldn't escape it
I was this was the feeling that hadn't
kind of no real trigger to it
um and I couldn't get away from it and
it was really really bad
um and then I think so my stomach would
feel really bad and then
um I found that you know a way to make
my stomach not feel bad was to put
things in it so I started to eat quite
compulsively and um at the age of eight
I ended up in Weight Watchers because
when I went to my first 12-step meeting
I'm like I like this I've been here
before yeah so yeah I mean my my mom and
my dad that tried really hard you know
they really did did everything they
could mum took me because that was the
only this is before kind of pediatric
kind of weight control [__] this is in
the 80s and that's all there was in
Brisbane
um and I think about the age of 17 I
left High School
at 112 kilos which is 250 something wow
like it was big I didn't realize you
were that big yeah yeah I was big I was
big and um I still got the stretch marks
and yeah as you know Mega body shame and
bullying and like terrified of having my
shirt off and like so afraid to have my
shirt off like would and I remember
being I was so big that I would always
swim with a t-shirt on because I was so
ashamed of my own body and
um I distinctly remember being on
holidays once with a mate up in
caloundra oh no uh mooloolaba
I was like 15 16. I was swimming in the
ocean in the surf and I was body surface
I always loved body surfing and I stood
up out of a wave and I looked down and
um there was blood spots on my t-shirt
because the T-shirt had rubbed my
nipples so much I was bleeding and um
yeah it was no fun so how did you how
did you like lose the weight and become
this sort of iconic Surfer you know the
the emblematic of like everything you
know youthful in Australia I was like
Andrew G yeah yeah I know right
um well the first thing that happened is
like I was I got unemployed
um in the early 90s
um we were at I think 12 years
unemployment in Queensland was a lot and
I couldn't get a job anywhere and I just
might I didn't do very well in high
school and I ended up sitting and I was
I had lived at home I was on the Dole
and I just felt my brain just going to
Mush because I wasn't being
for the internet you know there's so I'd
read all my books twice just sit there
and watch TV all day and I could just
feel my brain just going to porridge
because I wasn't getting stimulated and
I wasn't able to do anything and I just
got fatter and fatter and then one day I
um
I I I just felt and he's like oh [__]
I've got to go for a walk I've got to go
do something but I I've been trying to
go for a walk but I couldn't go out I
couldn't get out of the house for a
couple days and you know I had to do
something
and so I tricked Myself by saying I'll
just go check the mail because this is
before the internet
um the most exciting thing that happened
in the day was when the mailman came and
oh a sales catalog and so I my mailbox
is over here down my driveway but I went
that way and I walked that way and went
up around the block and I came back was
about 800 800 meters or so
and I picked up them out got the mail
and then I went and basically laid down
for about four hours because the most
exercise I've done in a long time and
I'll do that again the next day and then
the next and the next and it kind of got
easier and I was less breathless every
time just walking and then there was a
larger block around it was about a mile
uh one and a half K's or so and I
started doing that and I did that for
about a week and a half two weeks and
then one day I just I was doing this
every day and then one day I was like
I I started to feel this thing and when
I read your book I was like Ah that's
the thing that happened to me I just
felt this thing I was like I just I just
I just have to and I was suddenly I'm
you know kind of McLeod on the beach
with Sean Connery in Highlander that
terrible song but it's amazing I just I
had to start running
and I ran and like you're the wind in my
face and I'm like yeah and then I could
feel my chest was exploding and I my
heart was gonna explode and I I stopped
and I just kept walking I looked back
and I'd run the distance between two
telephone poles which was about 30
meters
and then the next day I ran
between one and then I passed the
telephone pole and I stopped at one
after that so I ran three and the next
day I ran four it was literally just
increasing above by 30 meters at a time
and then soon enough I was running the
whole thing and once I started that the
weight just fell off me man and um I was
about 19 so I'm you know right had
metabolisms on my side and uh I lost so
much weight so fast I reckon I lost
maybe 10 10 or 20 kilos about three
months like really quick really really
quick so I wasn't eating terrible food I
was actually eating okay and I remember
sitting next to a bloke I went to school
with at a bar and he looked straight at
me and didn't recognize me I was like
holy [__] oh it's because I've got a
chin
um it's been you know and then there was
that was there was a couple of times
that I went up and down through that
um I got bigger I got smaller I got
bigger I was smaller I never really got
a handle on what it was to understand my
own hunger
um but it was
um quite a bit later that
that I did
um eventually because I found out that
my relationship to hunger was I traded
it like my both my parents were refugees
what we grew up was my grandmother who
survived
um World War II and you know victory
over Hitler was fat kids so you know
sure get those calories in buddy and um
you know that was and that was it so
hunger was a thing to be terrified of
and this is not uncommon in
um the children of of immigrants or you
know
children of people who've you know been
through uh you know war or something
like that and so I
you know kind of understood that oh
hunger's just a signal after a while
hung it's just a signal and um I'll be
okay
and after a while I figured out I was
but that didn't come until only a little
while ago as far as you know getting it
was around about that time when I was I
was running a lot
um even though I was running things were
still hard I did feel better in my head
but things started to get quite hard and
I was very very hung up
um
and having really intensive obsessive
thoughts about
um of all things
um sexually transmitted diseases all
right and this is at a time when AIDS
could kill you it's a miracle that in my
lifetime you can be HIV positive and
have an amazing life and take prep every
day and not pass it on to somebody else
that's like unbelievable that is
Apollo program level breakthrough it's
astonishing because it was a death
sentence you remember it sure of course
I was living in New York City in my
early 20s and yeah it just it just
occupied a huge part of your conscious
awareness this terrify lingering fear
that you know it's terrifying and I was
becoming kind of somewhat sexually
active and
um you know I I had this completely
irrational responses to you know having
a having a pass or you know uh not
essentially sex but you know something
between that with uh you know somebody
that I'd met at a you know at a I was
working as a roadie guy I was on the
road with a bunch of old Road dogs and
um that's right I forgot about that he
showed me how to coil never forget it
I still think about it I'll teach you
how to I'll teach you how to deliver a
sick canine and roll a good cable let's
see you know those two things would be
fine and
um so he's really quite benign and
non-risky at all sexual behaviors I was
100 convinced I was going to die and so
I would show up at the clinic and demand
a blood test and go I'm gonna I'm gonna
I need you to give me this test because
I'm sure I've contracted this disease
and
um
and then yeah twice six weeks for the
results and those six weeks I'll be
planning my funeral I'm not even joking
it was so terrible
I think about the third time this
happened within about six months
this person at the clinic said
would you go see someone for me because
you've come here a few times now I want
you to go see someone and
amazingly you know we've got this
incredible Public Health System here in
Australia that's free
um your country may want to look into
that it's [__] great it's a whole
other podcasts I know right we also have
no guns on the streets but that's it
it's unbelievable as much of a dislike
the person in the government that did do
that that's they [__] did something
or that but uh
I've got extraordinary though like it's
so so lucky because I was starting to by
this point not really look at strangers
in the eye I was starting to get a bit
kind of Bucky rather than speaking to
people who I didn't know and starting to
get it I was 19. and it was the first
kind of tendrils of really kind of
serious [__] was starting to happen and
just Neurosis driving your life yes but
then quite quietly up and to the point
of like
like literally not being able to look
with people and instead of saying excuse
me like just not really being that's
starting to happen not all the time but
it was starting to happen and um so I
went to this outpatient clinic in
fortitude Valley in Brisbane which is I
guess now it's gentrified and amazing
but then it was like
the skin row or Hollywood like
Hollywood's not a nice place Hollywood's
a [__] awful awful awful place with
Hollywood is an idea oh sure not not a
geographic what is what does Greg proof
say there's no such thing no such place
as Hollywood it's a it's a collective
idea held at the same time by a hundred
thousand [__] basically it's a
perfect but like the actual place the
intersection well the intersection of
Hollywood and Vine has changed quite a
bit in the last decade but the idea you
know I I understand what you're saying
yeah and that it was like when you see a
bunch of tourists
looking for Hollywood yeah dodgy Place
dodgy place and methadone clinics and
stuff like that and I went to this
outpatient this mental health outpatient
clinic there and
I remember walking in and if you've
never been to an outpatient clinic for a
psych unit
that you'll never you'll like this smell
you'll never forget because you're
dealing with people who look
I'm literally
spending my days escaping Tyrion
Lannister coming at me on a dragon while
a drummer-based party of Hell Angels is
is screaming in every ear I I don't have
time to think about turning on a shower
you know that's just not even anywhere
near what they're thinking about because
there's no space and so
fat and cigarettes at the time sit
nicotine obviously you know easily
available down regulator
I remember going in there going [__] on
I don't belong here I don't belong here
and then I saw this really kind and
lovely psychologist his name was Mari
and
Mari started to I kept saying look I
don't belong here there's people out
there that you know you should be seeing
not me I'm I'm not crazy and then over
time it turns out I've
was
I did belong there and it was terrifying
it's a terrifying realization especially
in the context of a place like that
where you where you see people that are
very unlikely to rebound yeah and
reintegrate I was very lucky I was so
lucky to be caught by a public health
system and I I love my country so much
and I'll defend it
to the end because it stuff like that
you know there's this safety net this
public health system caught me I don't
know where I would have ended up had
those incredible people not seeing
something and gone you should really go
and have a chat
and she got me to a pretty good spot I
ended up um you know then I I finally I
ended up in an actual relationship with
an actual human being and that was nice
and I kind of got into radio and
um but it was about then that I started
really quite intentionally using
um alcohol and drugs to to manage what
was going on in my brain because look if
you if you don't know what's happening
but when you like for me I didn't really
know what was going on but I knew that
when I drank when I smoked weed it was a
little bit better it wasn't all the way
it's also highly reliable you know
exactly what you're going to get and if
you're walking around you know with this
like low-grade to high grade anxiety and
yeah you know this bundle of nerves and
and you know the energy that you don't
know how to contain or manage yeah and
you know you you
drink a few pops or you do what you do
and it's like oh there's a relief it is
hard to describe for somebody who who
doesn't have the itch but I would say
it's a release not a relief
because relief has an idea of like
it's it's going or gone for me it was
just
a reprieve yeah it was like ah just just
about the true peace from it was always
another beer
or another bump or another whatever away
and unfortunately the more that you
drink or use that gets further away like
you're in a nightmare yeah but we deal
with that later yeah yeah in the
meantime yeah like this is this works
you know it works until it doesn't work
but I think it's important to say that
it does work in the short term you
wouldn't keep doing it it was my
solution you know it's the oldest thing
in the world it's like it was alcohol
wasn't my problem it was my solution but
then what I the amount that I needed to
feel that all okay
uh to be around other people or when I
was in my house by myself to feel
dead noises and the shitty thinking and
all the horrible brain stuff going on to
make sure all that stuff was quiet
enough that I could just be still that
dosage became just too dangerous right
how long did it take for that to get
Unleashed I mean did you have because
it's socially approved uh and you can do
it out and open out in the open in
public
um
there is a sense of like oh okay well
I'm okay for now I can do that you have
an awareness from the get-go like if
this is problematic I think I was about
24 when
um my long-term girlfriend at the time I
remember being just so hammered trying
to walk I couldn't walk and um I was in
her lap she had a cross leg so I'm in
her lap and a very very long hair at the
time I was in a funk metal band it was
very long shorts it was the 90s and she
was brushing kind of chunky vomit soaked
hair out of my mouth so I could breathe
properly and she looked at me and she's
like you made me want to think about why
you keep doing this to yourself
because it's starting to get pretty bad
and I'm like I'm not an alcoholic [__]
off whatever I want so I think I was
about 22. maybe I'm having to stop
drinking and actually stopping drinking
like six 14 years later so it took 14
years
um and that wasn't the first
that was kind of the first time someone
had really seen that because I was
getting into amphetamines and things
like that point
um which was great because I could keep
drinking uh but it kept getting told to
me again and again and again and there's
that reaction just kept coming I can
stop whenever I want I'm fine and
Meanwhile your your kind of star is
ascending yeah yeah that seems to have
all happened really fast yeah did you
always like want the spotlight in that
way were you somebody who was like I
want to be on TV or I want to have this
kind of publicly facing role like how
did that all come about from being a
roadie to being on radio and then being
on television it started before that
actually I remember like that same
nervous kid that would you know be
terrified and you know be possibly
eating and going to Weight Watchers what
I think was about nine eight or nine
years old
um we had a school assembly every Friday
and our class had a it was every class
would put on a a sketch or something a
little play that we worked on it that
week and we all took it in turns and
because you know it was always like um I
don't know pick up rubbish at school
time or
um whatever you're doing don't
masturbate it Jesus is always watching
you like it was that kind of school
right so it was our play our turn and um
I'm on I'm ready I'm ready to go on
stage and I hear my queue and I walk out
and I see all these like hundreds of
kids all staring up at me like that and
the play was about
um picking up rubbish
um and I think the line was along the
line coming along the lines of don't
commit Us in put it in the bin and they
all [__] laughed and that was like oh
like when I first did you know proper
class A drugs I was like I know this
feeling I had this feeling on stage once
and it was where like what was anxiety
for me anxiety was uh lack of control
and lack of understanding what was about
to happen next and lack of control of
the situation and lack of lack of
certainty when I'm on stage I know
everything that's going to happen I know
exactly what's going to happen next I'm
the only one talking everyone else is
quiet
[Applause]
I just started chasing that yeah and
that you're associating those two things
in in a similar way yeah yeah using
drugs and being on stage are giving you
the same it was the same same feeling
yeah and it was a unfortunately my
coping mechanism became my career and uh
that worked but I think that's true for
a lot of people yeah
yeah that worked until it didn't I have
a very very different approach to work
now but for a while and it started to
get quite toxic
um there was definitely top Parts
towards the very end of my drinking and
using when I would just see then
resentment like if we were doing a TV
show together
um I would look at the script and go
um uh Rich excuse me excuse me Rich has
11 words and then I have nine then Rich
has ten and then I have seven like and I
got all the jokes it's such a cliche I
wish it was different mate I wish it
wasn't true but it's [__] true and I
was I considered it a com [__] a
wounding crime that this had happened
and how dare you how it's just the worst
it was awful it was an awful way to be I
hated that I that it felt like that I
hated that feeling
um I have a very different approach to
work now yeah no I know that I know that
but so you become this Andrew G guy
right you're essentially like a VJ on
this channel V which I'm trying to
imagine was probably not dissimilar from
mtvs Payday or whatever it was yeah
you're like a pop culture figure at that
point like yeah at least your generation
everybody knows who you are you got the
hair you got the looks yeah you're sort
of this uh symbol of Australian youth
somewhat and and you're getting you know
you're right and you're living large
right you're living here in Bandai and
yes you know lots of drugs lots of
partying uh lots of attention yes all of
that but it was also very much a
stop looking at me why aren't you
looking at me please stop looking how
come you're not looking like it was that
complete oscillation that was unbearable
um it was really weird it was very very
weird
um the the weird thing that happened
when I was on Music Television
uh was you know I was using alcohol to
cope with this it was a lot of stress
being on I was 25 you know and I've been
with radio for a long time and then
moved to Sydney left everyone
um my girlfriend and I came here and and
I was a heap of heap of pressure it was
so much fun it was the best job I ever
had it was unfucking believable I love
music man I don't get paid to talk about
music every day
all the biggest rock stars in the world
when they pass through yeah but not only
that it was also talking to like just
fans of music who live now you know how
huge our country is as big as as yours
all right the lower 48 at least
and people live people live 400 K's from
a post office I think it's it's I mean
I'm talking to people on satellite
phones who really want to hear their
favorite Ice Cube song and how do you
love ice cube I love him like you know
what do you do oh on my farm you know it
was unbelievable speaking to people from
all all across our community it was
amazing and I'm you know working in live
TV there's nothing like it mate it's
just it's just the best working as a
team and it's just so much fun but it
was a lot of stress and the thing was is
like the kind of revs per minute you
need to get up to to perform that kind
of thinking
three hours at a time that doesn't stop
at seven o'clock when you go off air
you know it's like oh what do I do what
do I do now what do I do is like I've
got a lot I'm coming in with no healthy
tools for down regulating yourself no no
so getting off and to the point where
like we would
I mean we would go on the road and um my
floor manager would hand me a beer as I
walked off stage you take my mic off me
and hand me a cold beer and you know I'm
in the music industry so the the first
first yeah so the the so so I was um in
2001 I was um I was on a work trip I
went to America for a work trip and it
was me and my producer Ben cameraman
Mike and um our Sando Andy and we were
it was my first time in Los Angeles
and we got caught in a riot I speak in
Hollywood for goddamn places sketchy and
it was a band called System of a Down
and they had no it was put on by a radio
station there and they had no real
security and I'd been around venues and
I'd you know seen some pretty wild stuff
happening both as a roadie and then
later on with the bigger gigs working at
V backstage and stuff like that and
going on tours big festivals so I'd seen
how badly you can go when even a couple
hundred people decide they want to go
that way and everybody else wants to go
that way it can be people can die all
right I saw it happen once it was awful
woof waffle and so we could see that
this kick was five minutes late and it
was ten minutes late and the capacity
was probably
I don't know they probably thought they
were going to have 1500 people like 8
000 people showed them and I don't have
to tell you I think I remember that was
it was it K-Rock put that on maybe yeah
was it out in the streets that's right
it was I do remember and it was Heavy no
no body searches no weapons checks no
nothing going into the place and it got
later and later and later and then it
became we sort of looked around and
realized we were standing with a bunch
of medium we realized
all everyone else is left
oh [__] and we were kind of cornered in
the back of this gigantic parking lot
that was about between five and eight
thousand people between us and the
street and they started to take the
backdrop down and that was it the place
just erupted and they were pushing over
speaker Stacks we watched we watched a
kid like she nearly got crushed by this
speaker stack with a footage of it like
it like brushed the back of her t-shirt
and and everyone's looking around and
there's my cameraman Jacko
we're filming all this and someone just
grabs for his um his his camera it's
about 120 Grand worth of camera and
everything pulled together and they grab
it and he pulls it back and then then it
became this like eight people are on top
of him and they're punching onto him and
you know my producer Ben drags him out
of there and then one of the ones
curated guy stayed behind and he had an
unscrewed a mic stand and this metal bar
just starts raining down on these people
that are on top of Jacko and I'm seeing
four arms and [__] like that and then we
drag Jacob out of there and I pull up a
chain link Cyclone Fence because it was
right behind Hollywood High
um I pull up this chain lean Cyclone
Fence and we got out underneath but
there now we're in a a score with these
20 length 20 meter high like 10 meter
high fences all around it like how do we
get out of here and some of those kids
followed us in like Jesus how are we
gonna get out of this and we climbed
over another fence and we we get out and
so I can't remember what street it was
it was one that ends up right by the
Montalban theater right
and we get out and we look and there's
like horses and Rye crops loading up
rubber bullets and like jacko's covered
in blood like what the [__] is this and
then out of nowhere between all these
cops who are staging around the corner
ready to go
this cab
just appears out of nowhere and like
have you ever have you ever held a cab
on the streets in L.A no never yeah it
was really scary and we thought you know
what's going to be amazing if we oh [__]
let's get out of here Jack I went to see
the sign on he was pretty [__] up and
like he was gonna be amazing let's get
the [__] out of here this was September
the 3rd like in a week from now we'll be
in New York City and we'll be
interviewing bands and we're having a
great time [__] yeah yeah
and then we were there we woke up we
were in New York City on 9 11. yeah I
didn't know that yeah it was and we were
safe you know but we were only 51st
something like that but it was
terrifying it was terrifying and
um so like the most unbelievable panic
attack and like oh I Pat I had panic
attacks so intense I fell asleep my body
just went and shut down and that was it
it was terrifying and it took us ages to
get out and like physically we were fine
took us about two weeks and two and a
half weeks to end up getting home to
Sydney we were coughing up black stuff
for about six weeks but that was about
it and I was physically fine but I
remember being at work and just staring
at the thumbtacks on the squishy wall of
my cubicle
at four o'clock I'd go on on air and go
and rich is asking for a Britney Spears
song and out of that and we're clear
I would do that and I know I'm just
staring there I'm normally a fairly
boisterous person sometimes and my boss
Jackie she comes by she goes you okay
I said no
would you like to see someone
yeah and amazingly she um she organized
a psychologist for me to go see I
specializes in debriefing you know
trauma response and things like that and
I went to go see this guy called Phil
and he had his amazing office up in
manly so you know I went surfing with
him you know we'd finish our session and
go sort of thing it was unreal unreal
and he says you've got PTSD I'm like
[__] off I don't have PTSD I'm fine mate
anyway okay there and he gets up
when he walks over to his bookshelf and
he pulls off this book this uh the dsm-4
which is like the the back before before
maps on your phone you would have this
big map of the streets right so it's the
essentially a street map where
psychiatrists can basically talk to each
other every condition yeah defined yeah
well that helps people who are talking
about the same patient to have an idea
of what's going on are we on DSM-5 Now
by now yeah it was four back then four
and he opens it to and he hands on and
goes read that I was like fine and I
looked down I was like
okay so someone snuck in here and uh
written some [__] out that they saw
while watching me and then put it in the
same font on the same grade of paper and
snuck it into this book because it was
like exactly what was going on now I had
to be an acceptance this was happening
and um
because of that I was like okay then
well what do I do about this he taught
me cognitive behavioral therapy which is
I'd never known before I'd never known
that you could just because I think it
doesn't make it real
took a lot of practice but I started to
work on that and that was really
interesting to get that initial kind of
idea that just because I feel it doesn't
mean it's real and just because I think
this is happening where's the evidence
for that maybe I'm no I'm not saying
that and developing that awareness and
that recognition is going to come into
play later well in a bigger way but the
recurring theme Here is is a willingness
to seek out and receive help not as
willing as I was to go yeah you know
what alcohol is way easier
let's delay that one right yeah it's
easier if I just drink and I'm see I'm
drinking red wine by this point rich I'm
not just drinking beer I'm a connoisseur
come on
I remember like buying this really
expensive bottle of red
hammered and I was going to open another
one and uh older black eye work which
you guys don't open it it'd be like
feeding strawberries to pigs
you could do all the CBT you want and
talk talk your ears off yeah with the
shrink yeah but if you're just hitting
the bottle and you know yeah doing all
the other stuff but it's only going to
go so far yeah but all that uh the
ability to question
and double check my thinking came in
really handy when it finally came time
to stop drinking because that's really
quite fun that's a fundamental leap you
need to make when you first stop
drinking you actually need to understand
that just because you see it that way
doesn't mean that's the way it is right
and that would have been a very hard
thing for me to get to
at the same time as everything else but
thankfully I had that experience
and I was very grateful for that um
I you know like most people I reckon I
took a good
I white knuckled it for a year
and all that was is you know I said well
it's alcohol it's uh
[__] freely available
wide widely legal self-administered
depression
um when you know in in this country you
there's so many drugs that are illegal
because they're worried that kids are
going to overdose but I can walk across
the street and buy enough gin to kill me
for 20 bucks
but it's completely fine yeah that's
[__] it's [__] [__] all right
there's a debate in this country going
on alone about legalizing medical
marijuana or legalizing marijuana like
right there's two drugs Rich Two drugs
that if you are drinking them or using
them to enough point and you stop
straight away you'll die
alcohol and benzodiazepines and both are
legal that's not okay
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
you get back from New York you're
dealing with the PTSD you're doing the
CBT you're drinking your career is
advancing yeah
um at some point you know you you you
move on and you're doing like you become
the host of American Idol yeah well
Australian Idol yeah Australia of course
yeah it's it's like a phrase It's like a
McDonald's franchise all right that you
sell the franchise all right you know so
I don't know say you create a you say
you create Finding Ultra the reality
show right you would then this is the
format
um there's the coach you know coach
house or whatever I know it works put it
in plug it in over here yeah you need
the champion you need the one who's got
everyone's got to have somewhere to go
you need the one who's trying to find
Redemption into the one who's trying to
find a reconnect with her daughter you
need the one who cries you need the one
who mate this is you need the right host
and it comes in a Bible Rich role is
going to be a host all right we'll get
Simon Hill to be the chef it's gonna be
amazing and then when you sell that
turkey they go huh okay so who's the
Australian Turkish version of this this
this this and you make money initially
it's a it's a franchise like anything
else and so yeah I was one of the hosts
of Australian Idol uh me and Jimmy
hosted it for I hosted it for seven
years he did it for six it was
unbelievable it was incredible it was
Unreal and it's capturing an audience
share that probably would be impossible
right so when you're hosting that it had
to be relatively surreal I know that
like even wasn't there what year was it
where the the um the finale was at the
opera house yeah and yeah we did
everyone there yeah right
yeah we did the first I think the first
finale the one in four adult Australians
watched that this is it was like the
Olympics don't get those kind of numbers
you know and it was just a it's a
Cornerstone of Australian pop culture
and
thankfully you know everything that I
mean Jim and I had been on air at
Channel V doing hundreds and hundreds of
hours of live TV every week every year
sorry and so by the time we get to Idol
is very funny because all the kind of
Network people like yeah but this is
real television boys like you know what
I'd get [__] all right like we
we put our reps in yeah yeah don't worry
don't worry and where are you with with
your mental health and with drugs and
alcohol at this point oh I was pretty
jumpy I was very much a you know it was
odd because while I was thinking
everyone was looking at me everyone was
looking at me
you know I had people walking up to me
in the street
um it's wild because it's 20 years later
right now I've got the same haircut
you're back I've had like five haircuts
yeah you guys in two times this is the
closest uh to Andrew that you've looked
at you know oh yeah yeah absolutely
without a current deal yeah totally and
um people I'll just be doing my
groceries man and people will come up to
me and grab my hair and pull it and
don't know it's not a wig
you know and their mates filming on
their shitty phone and like that would
happen in the middle of the day you know
I'd be out you know at a bar whatever
and people would come by and someone
bump my and I'd be would fly everywhere
and you know the guy would then turn
around like [__] whatever and I knew
enough to start I knew what to look for
and if the guy was there and he'd open
his body that way if I looked that way
there's someone filming on their phone
there I'm like sorry mate I'm sorry I
was anyway you know it just happened
every it would happen all the time wow
all the time
um it was yeah I mean look the thing the
thing when you got a job like that and
I'm sure you you understand what I'm
talking about you don't end up having to
pay for drugs they're just always there
oh thank you very much don't mind if I
do right you know and it's just it was
just half of the course man it was just
it was just all over the shop and
I remember trying I I started to
understand that I had a problem real
problem with alcohol when I um I met um
my ex-wife now and um there's a joke
among the acting community in Australia
I won't say her name because she's quite
a high profile Australian actress but
she said oh you don't think he got a
drinking problem until you leave
Australia
and then you get to America and go so
anyway
what it's it's five past 12 on a
Saturday I mean
okay more for me and I kind of realized
I went to the Middle East for the first
time and I was like oh wow our cultural
relationship with alcohol here is quite
[__] weird and not okay and quite
damaging and
I came back
and I I tried to not drink beer
for a year so I drink heaps of vodka it
was quite quite a class you got changed
horses but eventually just like a duck
to automators I was back on it and then
by about 2009 I could I was like bloated
again I was really fat
I started to um
I understood that I needed to stop I
needed and I tried to stop a few times
by myself I tried a bunch of times by
myself couldn't do it I reckon I've got
a couple weeks up at a time maybe six
maybe seven and then I'll be right and
half a sip of Heineken and then it's 2
am and I'm doing Jagermeister and you
know you're off it was there was no
abilities you kind of have to have that
experience to really lock into the
powerlessness of the whole thing yeah
and but it got worse you know and then
it got worse and then
um that TV show ended you know and I had
put no work in at all to see if I was
going to have any kind of continuity
career I I just expected that I was
turning away more than I would say yes
to I just expected the phone would never
stop ringing I would just expected that
it'll just keep going and going going
going going
and then that show went away
and I didn't know what to do
um it was around around the same time
that I was in America and um actually
Dan McPherson was in town and he and I
went for a hike on uh on the Runyan
Canyon and we was talking about [__] he
was over there for pirate season and I
slipped at the very top of running
Cannon we're descending and couldn't be
Rocky and slippery there and I slipped
and I did a like a kind of exaggerated
runner's lunge essentially on a bloomer
MCL in my right knee
and at that point it was the most
painful thing I'd ever experienced
and I took about 600 milligrams of
ibuprofen that night and I went to go
see my dogs the next day I was like I
said something happened to my knee and
like it's really hurts and he goes I'll
just take some ibuprofen I was like man
I took 600 milligrams last night it
didn't work it goes I'll give you some
Viking
and like five minutes later I'm standing
downstairs with 100 vodka and pills in
my hand he didn't ask me any questions
didn't ask anything and now
that is a that's a slippery slope
because it still [__] hurts
you just don't care
and when I mixed it with beer it was
like so
needless to say that was I reckon that
was January
yeah it was like January 2010 I was I
was in meetings by the middle of March
so that's what that's what ultimately
brought you to your knees yeah
absolutely yeah yeah literally because I
just could I couldn't not do it I
couldn't not do it and um it's a very
very slippery slope that stuff and so
like cut to like the last couple years
I've been through some pretty
interesting stuff with my hip and I've
had a hip replacement and some stuff
didn't go right with the surgery and the
pain was unfathomable but I I couldn't
touch those kind of drugs right because
like there was one point where we have a
our Emmys are called the logies here
that's TVs night of nights you know and
uh the first Logan yeah Australian Idol
ever won I've still got this guy on my
hand I've broken my hand snowboarding
and I I'd come back here I was off my
guts on Percocet because I was in I was
in North America and I said I said I've
got to fly back and I'm worried about my
hand
gave me this big tub of Percocet like
that and it's the kind of thing and I
took a pill in Vancouver and I woke up
in Sydney you know and
I uh I I I I know I held the lady in my
hand I haven't I do not remember you
don't remember anything not a thing wow
I'm not a thing yeah I'm on National
Television
at the peak of my career you know I
could have done anything and there was a
bloke I now work with the guy that no
guy by the name of Dave Hughes is
amazing he doesn't drink and a couple
months later I'd seen him on on radio
and I'd you know typical [__] with you
know it's sunglasses in the morning and
you know 6 a.m 6 30 radio
mate we've met before like I've never
met you mate I gave you a Logie
remember oh my God but the thing is like
in the in the you know Canon of like
hitting bottom it's it's you know it's
you could have gone a lot lower
you know but it is what it is the pain
threshold is what it is you know it
brought you in I'm you know and I've
heard you speak about this and I really
related to it in that I just have this
ability to withstand discomfort that is
different to other people
and we'll probably have stopped others
and I've had a number of doctors now
tell me going how are you still moving
hmm how did you walk in here they're
looking at my blood test going how are
you standing upright this doesn't work
how do you do this
I don't know man I just there's a bit of
my brain that won't stop
um part of it has given me the life and
the career I've have part of that is has
tried to kill me and it's managing the
the shitty part yeah and untangling that
is so difficult because when you're
forced to confront and break up with
your best friend this thing that you
think gives you superpowers you also
have to contend with that disposition to
go the extra mile that you're convinced
is the reason why you've been able to
make your way in the world and be
successful and do all the things that
you do and finding uh you know a
healthier more sustainable fuel source
energy source and and and putting like
putting that idea you know away and
understanding that it's a lie is is a
very you know
mountain to climb it is I was very lucky
in that as a incredible doctor here by
the name of Dr Ian Chung is I've had him
on the show he's an amazing guy he
really really helped me
and he's just kind of matter of fact he
told me goes I don't know yeah this is
OCD and I was like and I'd inflated like
a bouncy castle after a toddler's
birthday party like you know and he goes
wait wait wait like I can't tell you how
many
Olympians how many you know wallabies
it's a National Rugby Union football
team you know like lawyers like the
amount of people that have sat there in
that chair and I've told the same thing
too like come on why do you think you
got the career you've got I was like
what are you guys I said do you think
and he was talking about particularly
like there's an Olympic swimmer he says
do you really think that that kid who
will stare at a black line on the bottom
of a pool four mornings a week from the
age of eight so he can do it in Tokyo in
12 years from now doesn't have something
like that going on six mornings a week
and then yes six afternoons a week
precisely 12 times a day for you know
two hours at a pop do you think they
don't have something like that going on
because of course I've got something
like that going on of course they do
that's how they can do that it's it's
making sure that you only use it for you
know see it as a superpower and I was so
grateful that he helped me reframe it
like that it's like the bits that have
given you the life you've got you don't
want to lose those the parts that can
really you know be bad is when it gets
out control and and then it has you know
it has got to the point where it's
nearly killed me and it's learning how
to manage that stuff that is
um it's the kind of ongoing effort and
it takes
I know this is amazing TV show that I
really employ you to watch it's called
Bluey and there's a game in uh Bluey
called keep Yuppie where they're
basically just try to keep a balloon in
the air
and it's just basically that you know so
we're at the balloon in the airpod it
was holding the atlas ball above my head
like I'm you know before bjornsson in
the you know whatever it is the
strongest man in the world thing but now
it's just keeping a balloon in the air
but if I don't if I keep my eye off that
if I let the balloon fall pretty soon
within a couple of days things start to
get pretty pretty Grim yeah what's
interesting is with sobriety so I meet
you when you're like I don't know two
years in or something like that at that
yeah but only only a year of meetings
really okay and I'll be just on my
fourth and fifth or I met you yeah yeah
I was pretty White Knuckle oh wow yeah
but I was like without raw yeah well I
thought I could do it but
but not drinking and then doing all the
work not doing any work I was
essentially just come off my meds
without anything yeah you know so I was
like you ever go on like butter smooth
tarmac and then you missed a turn off
and suddenly you're on an ungraded
Gravel Road it was that yeah it was like
suddenly I was like what the [__] is
this I don't know what to do here
yeah so that brings you in but this is
on some level still the very beginning
of your mental health journey and
Adventures I was really lucky like the
bottoms that you've had with mental
health in sobriety are much lower than
the one that brought you in oh man into
the rooms in the first I was so lucky
that I'd stop drinking by then so so so
like oh you wouldn't have made it no
there's no way I would be dead
absolutely
um yeah things got really bad and it was
like like many things it's um you know
I'm a fan of the um uh uh uh Robert
Gonzalez book I think that's his name
Lawrence Gonzalez book Deep Survival
it's really good I try to read it like
once a year it's fantastic read it's
about what happens to your brain in
survival situations and um he he talks
about like real proper proper cataclysms
like mega mega Airline disasters and
things like that it's
not one thing it's not two things it's
like five to seven things in a row
that happen and by the time number seven
happens it doesn't matter because you've
got nowhere to go and it was like that
you know I was I was living in Venice
Beach
um I we had yet to get the green light
for another season of the show I was
working on so I had no work I was paying
rent out of my savings
um I was in a relationship with someone
who was wildly inappropriate
um it was extraordinarily you know uh
interesting and volatile okay but wildly
inappropriate and
um I was on a lot of stress
um my father was Ill back here in
Australia
and I didn't you know I was I was not
sleeping it'd been weeks since I had
actual sleep and I would I would if I
did sleep I would wake up and the bit
I'd strip the bed like it was laundry
day I was just thrashing around that
much that I would like the pool the
actual elastic Corners off the off this
off the bed I was thrashing around in my
sleep that much so I hadn't it didn't
weak since I had a decent sleep and
that's a real that's pretty bad if
that's happening there's a lot of red
flags and I was totally walking straight
past and then like just one day I
I woke up and I read I had my coffee
like I always do and I picked up my iPad
and I was reading the New York Times
like I always do and like they always do
they wrote in the corner right it's
going to be you know saying 72 because
it's LA and it's that's what it is every
goddamn day but then they wrote in the
tiny little Times New Roman font oh by
the way this is the 114th warmest
consecutive month ever recorded
passive aggressive passes that they are
but they would do that
and something my head just went
like that
and as far as I was concerned like there
was absolutely nothing we could do to
stop the full and completely cataclysmic
Untold Terror destruction end of the
world climate change disasters and it
was as far as I was concerned it was
happening today it was happening right
now and I was the only one that knew
about it and it was terrifying my brain
just went on this Cascade of of of
horror and fear and and I couldn't stop
the thoughts and what I normally would
do is I would run to manage my my mental
health and that would have been really
useful and I got to the point and I
loved it you know I got to the point
where I was running 10ks a day just
that's what I do I'd run from my house
and go touch the Santa Monica Pier turn
around run back and um on the weekends
you showed me that
um where the Nike missile silo was all
right I'll just go run that on a
Saturday I go run a trail half on this
on a weekend to do that that's what I
did on Saturdays I just tuned and that
was that fit I loved it and I was and I
used to make things pretty okay you know
that did a lot to regulate me but I
remember running
and I reckon I've got about
I've got past the skate park and I think
I got I got almost to
honestly somewhere a little further past
the skate park and you know I'm I'm
seeing things I'm seeing like those kind
of Baywatch Towers
um and they're they're floating like
they're on there they've got a big
concrete block and a chain underneath
them right and they're pushing against
These Chains floating in a now higher
sea level all right and I look up and
these the tops of the palm trees I look
up and now I'm looking at them as if
they're underneath of lily pads you know
because I'm now on the new sea floor and
I can see I'm seeing it like do you ever
watch Mr Robot
yeah yeah they did that really well when
I watched Mr Robot he's having those
breaks from reality it's like when I
watch BoJack Horseman I'm like someone
knows someone knows in the writer
Jerusalem so in in Mr Robot they I
remember talking to Audrey going it's
that it was that it was that where it
kind of glitches in and out yeah like it
wasn't all the time but I wanted to I
wanted to warn people I wanted to grab
people and go don't you understand like
it's all good and I knew I knew enough
like if I want to grab people and warn
people and you see that you see people
who are struggling really badly shouting
on the streets you see that because
that's the symptom if you want to try
and help everybody I was like [__]
hell I want to I want to and I was their
thoughts hurt they were coming and they
wouldn't stop and they hurt like I was
chewing on our fire or or you'd poked me
with a barbecue skewer right and so it's
like this and they would come at me and
I started to Flinch and push them away
like they were mosquitoes I was like if
I gotta get home so I turned around I
didn't run that far maybe only two three
K's turn around and came back and I'm
running and I'm scrunching like I'm
making noises like every time it hit and
I'm flinching like this and um up ahead
of me on this on the path I see this guy
and he's shuffling now if you've never
been to that part of the city of that
part of the world like complex untreated
conflict mental illness on the streets
yeah in California it's terrible it's
terrible it's a complete tragedy that
the richest country in the world allows
it to happen and that police are
untrained and unable to deal with it
when it goes bad and they people would
die by cops all the time and it was
awful awful tragic and up ahead of me on
the path I see this guy he's kind of
shuffling along he's got no shoes on his
pants are too big for him so he's
clearly not eaten in a while he's got
this big Bloom of urine he's clearly
peed himself
and I run up along next to him and two
things really hit me is like he's
younger than me
he's got this kind of shaved piece of
his scalp there so I don't I don't know
what's going on but he's got a shaved
part of his scalp and he's doing the
same thing he's going and he's doing
this I was like oh [__]
and I know you were at that moment the
only thing was dip so I knew something
was wrong I don't know if he knew
something was wrong
I ran home I ran upstairs and I called
my
um my mentor David uh he's a guy that
guides me on my sponsorship his spot
he's my sponsor so I called David
and I'm like he's like hey buddy I'm
like Climate Change is Gonna [__]
business
I did not draw breath before as far as I
did was he gonna die so there's no food
get your family out of here
I just couldn't stop it was like it's
called um plosive speech right I was
just and he says okay two things mate
number one this is way beyond my pay
grade you need to get to a doctor right
now and number two you're really lucky
because crazy people don't know they're
crazy so you better get to see your
doctor fast yeah you had a little bit of
self-awareness of what was happening but
at the same time this is real like in
your mind these things are actually
happening oh yeah it was they were and
they weren't and that also caused a huge
amount of pain
because I knew they kind of were and
kind of weren't and I I didn't want to
accept that it was happening and it was
enormously painful and this went on and
on and on and on and eventually I went
to go see my psychology my psychologist
I finally got to go see him I had to
wait the whole weekend
and then I go see did it feed or you
were in this persistent stage it was
pretty bad
it kind of came and went quite a bit it
was really bad and I went to go see him
and he had these aims recliners like
this beautiful beautiful place and I sat
on the edge of this and I said might you
get a jail for guns you get a gun can
you hide and big big arm because like
this you remember Rodney King you
remember the rise remember how the seed
was on fire that's gonna happen again
there's gonna be fridge I was just
like going for it and he goes hmm
mate you're experiencing a form of
psychosis this is paranoid delusions and
at the moment I was like oh
he's in on it he's a [__] climate
denier
and at that point I was like oh [__]
part of me whether it's God or Buddha or
Prince or whoever it is that watches
over me I was like hang on a second if
you don't believe him
this you're in trouble and
I was like okay well what does that mean
but that was the first thought in my
head you had a shroud that was still
Tethered to the real world my first
thought was like he's like he's in on it
he's he doesn't know he doesn't know wow
it was so scary it was so scary and he
told me you know he told me what
psychosis was and that you're really
going to need proper medication and you
need to go see a psychiatrist and I'm
like yeah I'll be fine without meds dumb
idea dumb idea eventually I did get meds
and um it was Terror it was terrible
because and this is a really hard part
it's like this [__] doesn't stop and and
really painful and it was happening
every five to eight seconds
and eventually
my brain started to consider
and come up with ways to make it stop
unfortunately it was a very permanent
solution to what was a temporary problem
I was I was back in the Middle East I
was shooting a TV show I was I had a job
that I was going to go do and so I was
doing this job in the Middle East
and I was in this hotel room and this
idea popped into my head and it wasn't
like
oh my god I've got a it's just not
working out with this girl I'm saying
I'm gonna have to call her I gotta be a
man I've got to [__] call her and I'm
gonna see her I'm gonna look her in the
eye and tell her it's all and like you
know the kind of nervousness you might
feel with my idea like that like I'm I'm
gonna have to break up or whatever I'm
gonna have to fire someone it wasn't
that it was like
when you're doing your ocean swimming
right when you're doing your Othello
thing
round about I don't know mile 40
a thought of a hot shower and he went oh
man that's gonna be so good I'm gonna
get on the hot shower I'm gonna peel
this wetsuit off and I'm gonna do a wee
and I was gonna care and I was gonna
feel so amazing gonna feel my body warm
up
that's what it showed up as I thought it
would show up as some super scary thing
it showed up as like the best kindest
most amazing
thing that I could do and again rich I
was so lucky because I'm like hang on a
[__] second if I'm convinced that the
forests are on fire right now and the
sea is rising like how is this not also
a distortion how is this not also not
real
and I got on the phone I just started
calling people because I had been
trained through my time and you know for
sobriety as like before you pick up a
drink pick up the phone so I just
started calling people and I reckon I
was on the phone I just looked at where
the sun was
wherever it was in the world and like I
know someone that lives near there hi
you haven't spoke to me for about a year
I just started calling people just to
check on the I was called my brothers
because it was Australia was awake so I
called two of my brothers and we were
FaceTiming and Skyping and stuff and
just checking on the world with their
brain and being really aware that I I
wasn't able to process things very well
um it was so frightening mate and this
went on for a long time yeah I mean that
the oscillation between
catastrophe and then that Blissful State
and understanding that that's just a
different version of the same thing is
also a level of self-awareness that
probably saved your life my but the
thing is dude like I I remember when you
went to the Middle East like we were
hanging out around that and you would
share with me like I'm having issues
with my mental health and I didn't
I didn't fully appreciate or understand
what you were actually going through
right I don't think it was until and
this I think was much later when you
came over to the house and and Mel our
friend Mel was over and and we were
having like a tea ceremony we served you
we served you tea oh yeah when Wuda was
there yeah
and uh and you were convinced that the
tea contained some kind of mind-altering
substance without a shadows and freaked
out and laughed and it really scared me
I might as well have done Iowa's because
I was I I bore witness to a small slice
of what you were going through and that
it wasn't until then and this probably
this was much after this was this was a
couple years I was still pretty fragile
I was still pretty fragile yeah and that
that's when I realized like oh wow like
this is
is he serious oh yeah it was really and
what is the what was the diagnosis I
mean you had this
psychosis this episode was psychosis but
is it is it bipolar is it like
schizophrenia no it was it wasn't
schizophrenia
um it it was you know from what I
understand is like
what I was experiencing was a really
acute
um it's like this is what like untreated
anxiety in uh OCD and as a Founder later
on ADHD all that stuff spinning me up
into this place of extraordinary anxiety
will then start to pop up into
um
up into psychosis because what's uh
Neurosis is when I you know you you
break a leg or you lose a job or you
know your your partner leaves you and
even a rational fear and it's well it's
it's the pain caused by not being able
to accept reality all right that's
essentially Neurosis so like this is the
thing that is actually happening I don't
want to accept it so it really hurts all
right because I don't like I have this
job or my lover or can walk
psychosis I've got to explain uh to me
that psychosis when that pain becomes so
great your brain starts to reinterpret
interpret the reality to keep you safe
and so it I started to realize that
um I was observing things through my
site my taste my every input it's like a
touch
was being filtered through this bizarre
kind of distorted cataclysm of Doom and
I wonderfully and very gratefully I'd
learned how to meditate at some point
and um like Watkins oh yeah wait God
we're just dropping every Venice Beach
name ever here right and he's coming
back on the show on it pretty soon oh
cool man and
I was in Amsterdam because I was going
to business school over there and I'm
I'm meditating in this amazing Airbnb on
the canal and it's unbelievable and I'm
in in meditation and um doing that thing
that um uh what's his name it's got a
funky voice
uh the Austrian sat on a bench yeah you
are looking at the pan body what you'll
see like I was doing that right okay so
I'm meditating a meditating and just
just enough breasts between me and the
thoughts all right just to watch some
more go by like that and I was like huh
I don't see anybody else freaking out I
don't see anybody else worried about
that I mean people are concerned and
that's normal but
I'm the only
maybe something's ah and it was only in
that it's only being able to meditate
and observe my own thoughts being that
distorted I understood and amount of
trouble I was in so I pretty quickly
went to go see a psychiatrist back in
Santa Monica amazing guy
super [__] smart really smart and he
just looked at me and they said mate I
never lose
the only tricky part is getting the
dosages right but once we get the
dosages right you'll be fine and I
really wanted to believe him because I
was thinking about suicide 20 times a
day and that's a really [__] hard
thing to do a hard thing to deal with
and that went on for a really long time
and this is the thing about about meds
um I think I was on I'm on my ninth
different iteration of medication right
now and it's actually doing pretty well
you know um but it's all in titrating
and it's all in getting the dosages
right
um
but you know for a while there I was on
two kinds of antipsychotics and ssris on
nsri I was putting on a kilo a week from
all the
um from away because I [__] with your
insulin yeah antipsychotics
and um but eventually you know it
started to kind of get get better and um
the meds the meds work but the meds
don't do the job for you and the way I
would describe the way I describe
medication for this kind of thing mate
it's like you are in the world of
cycling
um I can take all the EPO that I want
right uh I can dose myself like you know
I was on the Postal Service team and
whatever but I've still got to Pedal my
[__] balls off to get the top of the
outerwears all right you still got to do
the work it's not like I inject this and
my bike magically gets to the top of the
mountain hey gold jersey no you've
you've seen photos of those guys who are
on the gear they're ah pain faces
they're all on it but they're all you
know they're not all of them
depends on which documentary you watch
uh a lot of them are on it like you've
got to really do the work and the meds
let you do the work
if you don't do the work it doesn't get
better the meds give you the space to do
the work and
wonderfully through the support of a I
have a psychologist and a psychiatrist
so the psychiatrist is like the like the
mechanic who makes sure that the engine
works right and the psychologist is the
rally driver
um the Navigator it's like you know 45
turn in five three 90 to return unless
you know they do Shadow all the turns to
the rally drivers the chat all returns
to the rally drivers so I've been
working with two people for quite a
while now and getting back here I met
this amazing guy I had him on the show
the other day his um Dr Adam Bayes he's
um actually leading uh leading the
research into psilocybin and the
treatment of treatment resistant
depression here in Australia it's
amazingly smart yeah and that's
interesting are you are you what is your
perspective uh for yourself with respect
to those compounds mate I've I've seen I
did a whole documentary about suicide
prevention
um uh it was incredible and I I've you
know I've met people who are going
through
um TMS and dtms and experimental
ketamine therapy and stuff like that so
I've I've actually spent a fair bit of
time with people who are you know
dealing with chronic catastrophic
treatment resistant depression it's
horrible horrible it's not the sort of
thing you can have a smoothie a nice
walk and you'll feel better like this
your brain switches completely set to
doom and you cannot move them
um
what's really interesting about
psilocybin is that the way what it does
to the brain is that and certainly the
way that Adams describes his study is
that with very little treatments maybe
only two treatments but they're quite
intense there's two psychologists they
go in for a long time and it's really
really uh important that it's done in a
very particular way
um with only one or two treatments you
can have a humongous
um and that's amazing because I'm
someone who you know dealt with the side
effects of medications like your
testosterone goes out the window and I
met Audrey in the middle of all this all
right so for me the woman is now my wife
and the mother of our kids
with the testosterone that's like to try
to explain what no testosterone is like
from these drugs it's like hey you're in
the woods and it's raining and you need
a light of fire here's a box of matches
no matches in the Box
like it's really yeah it's hard I mean
it's not hard but you know it you know
what I mean like it's it's a real drag
um look unfortunately Adam told me
because I've had a psychosis and I've
had to participate in the truck
[__] oh wow that that obviates
you from yeah I'm not allowed I'm not
allowed to play interesting no I mean I
I ask certainly you know there's all
kinds of of
um evidence of the efficaciousness of of
these compounds with these resistant
conditions I mean there's no question
about it I think it's very exciting to
see that unfold and and you know with
the development of these new therapies
that are are undoubtedly helping lots of
people but It's Tricky especially when
you're in recovery like it's like is
this because you know my brain lights up
and says yes please well it's like this
is a thing we're 50 years behind on the
research because this stuff started to
escape the labs and there was some
studies I don't know how they're going
to prove but there were studies where
the doctors were taken at the same time
as the patients and all the research got
shut down I was like so yeah I know yeah
and we lost Decades of yeah
that would have that would have advanced
that and it's certainly it's not
something that you want to you know do
in your backyard with the work whose
name used to be John but now calls
himself you know Panther forest or
whatever there's a lot of those where's
the bare skin has a lot of people
there's a lot yeah there's a lot of that
going on right now no you want a proper
psychiatrist but my Adam sorry so Adam
was super smart and he's super smart and
was willing to question his initial
hypothesis because I'm on all these meds
and it still wasn't right it's like what
else is going on something else is going
on and so we came down off all these
meds
it has to do a week without them and I
was doing breakfast radio at the time
and I had a you know just [__] living
the dream I was doing breakfast radio
from my house I had a line into my house
just go down in the basement dude
and so he said okay you need to do a
week without to give you so it can work
when you came back on the other ones and
he said uh here's some you know Valiums
and I came home and I had them in my
hand and I gave them an order and I said
hide that give them to me when I'm being
a bastard don't tell me where they are
because me and Valium are my prince
Valium has ridden me into the sunset but
also you're titrating off all of these
powerful I was over quite a while it was
over a number of weeks but that one week
man I remember telling the radio people
I was with it was one morning
I had three people I was on the show
with within the space of the first hour
each of them texted me going [__] your
fastest morning [__] you're funny this
morning man what the [__] you're amazing
today and I was like the radio person
that I always wished I could be but the
rest of the day I was like I just
couldn't I couldn't handle that
operating speed
like no wonder I used to you know drink
and use so much to slow it down a lot
yeah I couldn't do I couldn't I couldn't
and that broke my heart a bit because I
was that's fun also you must be thinking
oh wow like let me just like that's uh
you know how can I have more of that as
my career superpower well maybe not is
there a euphoric kind of feeling with
that also
um I think it was more the
you know that uh it's the thing that I
guess got me in the door and got me
quite quickly up the ladder but by this
point I was unsustainable and it kind of
broke my heart because I had to face
that I wasn't able to you know I mean
even Lewis Hamilton's got breaks you
know I didn't I wasn't able to stop it
and that was the hard part I wasn't able
to regulate from that and that was a bit
sad but I understood I was able to come
to like well I can do this or I can be
safe and have a life and be able to have
relationships with people and I think
I'd rather the latter
um so Adam we started he said he started
treating me for OCD
and once we changed all the OCD meds
things started work really well and with
a number of weeks things got pretty good
um and then I went and saw a acceptance
commitment therapy
um psychologist and then I got really
stuck into the ex into um uh basically
exposure therapy which is terrifying and
horrible and
I remember I was on just kind of you
know Garden variety selective serotonin
react Inhibitors by this point
um which has helped Grease the wheels
you know and help give me the space to
do all the
the work essentially and rewiring the
neural Pathways I needed to do and my
exposure therapy like this is the point
where I would drive my car in LA and I
had my car on the dashboard had the word
climate control written on it the word
climate made me want to ship my pants
and vomit at the same time like I was so
so sensitive to any kind of trigger like
I would walk out the door and if I felt
the warm sun on my skin I'd be terrified
this is years later this is like 2016
2017 this is still happening it was the
worst and so I was like I can't live
like this I cannot do this every day I
will not do this there's got to be
another way there's got to be another
way and so I went and found Janine who's
amazing and
you know I would I would sit there with
her and
she had these really interesting
pictures and she's sitting next to me in
her office
she had an iPad and it was a art project
I think where they took photos of really
famous parts of London and New York and
I think
I was one of the city
um I think it was Los Angeles I like the
bull in downtown man we're near Wall
Street that big ball statue it's like 90
centimeters above the high tide Mark all
right and there was this picture and you
can put your finger on it and swipe it
that way and it would give you an
artist's impression of what you know
when the West Antarctic ice shelf melts
was three meters or so of sea level what
that's going to be
and I would swipe it back
and I would do this for about 10 minutes
just shaking in Terror and wanting to
[__] myself and wanting to vomit and
then she would kind of talk me down
through her and then we would I'd go
back you know a little while and we'd do
something very similar and do it again
and do it again and then it got to the
point where I was shooting a TV show on
Fiji my wife's from Fiji
and people don't give a [__] about sea
levels in Australia because like it
doesn't affect them but let me tell you
in Fiji there's villagers that have been
there for hundreds of years where you
know the village used to be as big as
this table now the village is this big
because it's just been washed away all
right and I would sit there and there
was a village right next to where I was
staying and I would sit there every
afternoon
um Sometimes When the tide was high and
so I'd sit there as the tide was coming
in and I'd look to my right and I'd see
the water washing up underneath the
houses and you know you could see where
they bury their ancestors on the land
you know and you can see where their
ancestors were buried and like pretty
soon they're going to have to move the
grave or they're gonna be seeing bodies
and
and it was horrible but I did that every
day I did that I just forced myself to
be with it every single day and I still
do it every day like if I see us if I
see a headline that would I would
otherwise have previously shied away
from I will click on it and I'll read it
and I will be with the discomfort and it
is only it's like anything Rich it's
only in being willing to be with the
discomfort that
we then get the adaptation response and
that goes for your muscles it goes for
your endurance it goes for your mental
health
if you the more you run away from it the
worse it gets unfortunately like the
less you run it's not you don't run
faster the less you run the slower you
run so you know
it's only willing to be with the
discomfort that any change happens
you don't have to do heaps just a little
bit I think the magic number's like four
percent or something it's just a little
bit but just enough just enough to
to be with it and then adjust a little
bit easier the next day but then you
make the discomfort a little bit harder
and then slowly the thing is mate if I
if I ran away from everything that
scared me I'd live my life on the head
of a pin
and what does that give me that gives me
gives me no options it gives me binary
it gives me I don't want that so I'll
hide and that's not a lot of choices to
go through life with but if I'm willing
to be with the discomfort suddenly I've
got possibility
if I'm willing to be with the discomfort
and go okay this is awful I wonder what
wonder what could happen here because
I've only ever known what that looks
like what could this be like if you if I
approach it tried a project with
curiosity and be aware of how painful it
is but also go well
what else is happening here because it
might not be as bad as I think or it
might I might I don't know all the
answers someone else has probably got a
pretty good idea
this isn't being with that Curiosity and
being with that willingness to be
uncomfortable that that's that is what
has allowed me to actually have a have a
life now I can sleep at night I'm so
sorry that you've suffered so much and
it's so much more than than I originally
realized and
it's a credit to you and your commitment
to getting well that you're able to sit
here because I think you know a lot of
people perhaps the majority of people
who have who might have found themselves
in a situation where
you know they're seeing things that
aren't real they don't make it back from
that I know they end up in those
institutions that have that smell that
you can't forget and unfortunately
that's the common sort of
scenario that's how that generally plays
out I'll get really lucky as I said I
got really lucky because I learned that
just because I think it doesn't make it
real I learned that a long time ago
afford it you know I didn't want to how
do you know today
when to differentiate you know what I
mean like I do a lot of this is
happening right now are we here yeah I
mean we're here everything's fine right
now you're you're locked in you're right
I have no problem really checking I have
no problem checking and for a while I
would be
um I
I will check uh sometimes I could not
understand uh emotions in a room and um
that turned out that you know it's the
ADHD diagnosis but I'll not be able to
understand things and I'll check I'll
like say if I've done a promo thing and
I'm doing a radio interview and I give
one of the you know one of the anchors
or one of the hosts some [__] and they
go 7 15. oh see you later man I'll walk
out nice to publish this did I [__]
blow that are they upset at me no okay
because my head is telling me that I've
just destroyed my career my relationship
with that person I'm like nah you know
okay okay so then every time my brain
goes you [__] blowing you're blind
I'm like but hang on
um that Peter said it was fine and I
just remember that other thing that the
other person talked about yeah
my brain I can't you know I can't
imagine how terrifying it must be to not
know whether something that's happening
is real or not yeah it's not fun it's
just absolutely terrifying it's it's
because you've never
yeah it's so scary it's so so so scary
um but
I don't know man and is there a sense of
of
like what's the origin story here like
where does this come from is this a
genetic thing is this you know a result
of a series of traumas that went
untreated for a certain period of time
is it even worth trying to understand
that or is it just about like I know
what I need to do now to be well and
stay tethered I think it's I think it's
worth trying to understand it for the
purposes of you know well then what can
I do about it and how can I deal with it
properly and yeah I'm a son of two
people that had to leave their countries
because of War all right and that's
going to change you as a person
and who they were when we were little so
there's a there's a there's a
possibility of like an epigenetic
absolutely trauma passed down yeah
I had to check and I said yeah yeah
you're about 50 50. you're about 50 50
of like what comes from your parents and
50 of like what happens after you get
born
um and so look like I said you know this
is the brain I've got it's the brain
that gave me the life I have probably
didn't help it by drinking and using so
much and literally you know giving it
the Jimi Hendrix Zippo on the Strat you
know just I drank holes in my brain or
maybe it saved you maybe it was what you
needed in that moment you know to sound
like a Dominic recall going on there
Richie yeah well it was it was a it was
a you know on some level of coping
mechanism yeah precisely yeah and that
was and you were living a very Surreal
Life yeah it was very weird I'm very
lucky I'm very and I don't you know like
I'm a white straight middle class man
okay so I can I can
you know I could have been weird on the
street and walked past the cop and they
would have not looked at me twice
because I had this job on TV I was just
having a big night if I was any other
color forget about it you know I'm very
I'm aware of that it's like I'm not
aware of that I'm very lucky that I'm
you know in a country that has access to
healthcare and I'm really lucky really
lucky the one I really needed like a lot
of intervention I could afford it you
know but you also volunteered for it
a lot of people resist it or they're
they don't have that tiny little piece
in the back of their mind I didn't want
it that's still clinging to reality like
you're like I need to call this person I
need to call this person this person
says come here and let me help you and
you show up don't let me don't let me
mislead you yes sir like the here's this
antipsychotic I want you to take it only
when you need it aha if I don't take it
I don't need it I'm not sick and I would
do that you know right I would I did not
want I didn't want to accept that I had
this I did not want it and I I I avoided
dealing with it for a long time way too
long and I'd cause myself another's a
lot of damage doing so
it's one thing uh to raise your hand and
say you know my name is Rich or my name
is Asher and I'm an alcoholic or I'm an
addict we're in a we're in a culture now
that's that's forgiving and
understanding and and has a grasp on the
recovery process and and you know we
understand that on some level it's
another thing altogether to say you know
my name's Usher and you know I had a I I
have psychotic episodes or sometimes I
don't know what's real and expect people
you know to be like cool you know are
you you good you're gonna show for work
it's okay like so yeah what I'm getting
at is that I still think we have a long
way to go yeah in terms of understanding
these types of conditions
um and and and I think what's important
about
you know you and kind of how you
advocate in this space is your
willingness to be open about it like I
remember when I was here a couple years
ago and you did a live show and you got
up in front yeah that live audience and
yeah maybe I don't know if it was the
first time you've done that but it was
early in your journey of saying I'm
gonna get up and I'm gonna tell this
story yeah and it's hard you know it's
embarrassing I have to talk about things
that like a lot of people might look at
me a little bit differently you know as
a result of it oh um but I think that
there's so much power in your in your
there's a lot of Courage uh to be that
vulnerable in front of people well
firstly like it's been a long time since
I've had any breaks with reality like uh
it's been a long time since I've had any
of those episodes and I'm I live every
day knowing that they are it won't be
tomorrow might be in six months but
they're not far if I don't keep things
Ship Shape you know you got so little
the balloon yeah it's important I got to
do I go to there's things I need to do
sure but because of the things that I do
every day I have this incred terrible
life that I'm more productive and you
know than I've ever been in my career
yeah and you have like a million jobs
let's be straight I mean you you know
like I don't know how many TV shows you
host but it's a lot I only seem to have
many podcasts and you're doing this news
thing now like a live event it's a lot
of fun uh you know this sort of live
Colbert pretty much experience with news
and comedians yeah it's really
performers here in Australia like you're
incredibly productive I don't know man I
got a lot in my head and I've got to get
it out and I'm trying to trying to get
it out in the healthiest way possible
um but that was Sonya talked about
before that I've just lost it now you
were talking about
um it's like coach oh yeah so
when I first got sober all right
I remember sitting there was a
particular meeting I would go to
and uh I'm I'm a part of a a fellowship
of men and women who count days and take
steps is more than 11 there's less than
13. you can figure it out the secret
thing that we're not supposed to talk
about but everybody knows what you're
talking about and
um and I would sit there and I remember
this particular place it was on as on
Sunset was above a bar I don't know if
you ever went to that one oh I know
exactly
and so I'm singing This Bar in the
middle of the day and um
this guy comes up to me and it's
probably about my age now and he goes
mate it's gonna be okay I said you know
I understand like I was literally
sleeping on my friend Nick's spare bed
you know I'd just been you know I had to
go kicked out of my house I was like
getting divorced it was like oh I was no
one could have told me anything and he
goes no it's going to be all right
promise you it'll be okay just keep
coming do this do that do the things
that your man tells you you'll be all
right he may as well have been telling
me the story of Hansel and Gretel it was
a [__] fairy tale right it may as
well have been hey Rich come over and
say hi to you know the kids come say hi
to Audrey but I'm going to blindfold you
and when you get into the house I'm
going to take the blindfold off and say
hey man describe the colors of the cars
on the street he'd be like
why neither there
I like you just blank like a complete
blank from where I was standing that day
to this guy he was wearing a gray gray
over cut never get him
but I just needed to believe that that
was possible and he was telling me it
was possible and I had to believe that
he was telling me the truth and all I
had to do was just go he told me just
just do what your man tells you do it
come here every day do what your man
tells you it'll be all right and guess
what it was and I'm just trying to give
to others what was given to me because
you can't be what you can't see all
right and when I first came back here
and I was like I'm gonna go to these
meetings I'm gonna call my man David I'm
like I'm so famous I don't want to go to
a meeting put my hand up I know if you
realize I'm really [__] famous he's
like dude shut the [__] up put your
[__] hand up and you'll [__] save
someone's life man [__] you I was like
okay so
and and since then you know it's not
about me it's not about me it's about I
want to I want me
at 22 getting his you know long vomit
soaked hair getting pulled out of his
mouth to see someone like me not me but
someone whoever they relate to
talking about this and going yeah it
doesn't have to be that you can have
everything you've ever wanted more or
then you could ever [__] dreamed of
without that thing
it's okay you've got a brain that when
it gets that thing bad [__] happens it
doesn't happen to everybody sorry it's
like peanut butter not everyone gets to
eat it you know
I'm just trying to give to others what
was given to me mate and it was you know
I found that you know if you can't
you've got to seek out stories of people
who are where you want to be
that's why people read your book because
they're like they want to run 5k they
read stories about you running Ultraman
but they want to they want to get off
their ass and go and do something all
right so people go and read stories they
already they read Goggins book right
because they want to hear they want to
read a story about someone who's where
they want to be and understand that
another person has done this thing
and I'll do the same thing like when I
was dealing with all the suicidality I
started a podcast
um I was doing it was movember I
convinced November to fund the podcast
and I spoke with I spoke with suicide
survivors I feel like I know I did 40
episodes or something and so every like
I don't know every third or fourth
episode I spoke with suicide survivors
and I'm talking to these guys going wow
and I'm like literally if you watch the
footage just before we did video podcast
you've watched the footage I'm like
going through it and I'm speaking with
them and like this [__] flying through
my head and I'm seeing [__] like it was
all happening oh my god dude it was all
happening and I'm just going hold listen
listen and it was really important to
hear that you know these people had been
through while I was the kind of thinking
that I was going through having their
brain try to tell them
yeah I can fix this it's gonna be fine
just do this to this and then after a
while just it's it's way more seductive
than I thought and when I heard that I
know you'll do a big warning at the
start of this because there's a lot of
got to be really careful about how you
communicate about it this sort of thing
um
I didn't realize how seductive the
thought it was
I didn't realize that at all
I talked more about that what do you
mean I didn't well like I was saying
earlier like I didn't realize I thought
it'd be a big scary scary thought like
and this is what I'm gonna have to do
now oh well I've tried and this I know
it was hey man I gotcha come over here
let me put my arm around you just do
this and be a little better because it
was so noisy man it was so noisy it was
like being
I don't know stuck at the worst music
[__] worst EDM music festival ever
and it's at a drag strip in your five
hours from anywhere and you can't get a
ride home and you can't sleep because
you've taken too many drugs and you
can't get out of it because your friends
are somewhere and you're stuck between
the drum and bass 10 and the trans tent
and you've got all this [__] blowing at
you from speakers either side it was
just so noisy I like my brain was so
noisy I couldn't [__] think and you
got this guy going
be quiet
and that's [__] hell man it was like
and it was my voice it was my feelings
it was my idea you know the case the
same one that goes oh man I'm gonna make
a best chocolate smoothie it was the
same thing it's like oh I'm really cold
I'm gonna put on my favorite jumper it
was the same thing and that's I was very
lucky that I knew that it's so scary
yeah and I that's the thing I needed to
tell people about it doesn't come out
scary it comes out as the best idea
you've ever had
it's that thing we were talking about
this yesterday like you can't you're
trying to solve the
problem
with the same brain that created the
problem like you're you're living inside
a brain that is tweaked yeah and you're
trying to figure out a way forward but
all you have is this tweaked brain but
you don't really know that it's tweaked
and you're so you're stuck it's like a a
strange kind of like Hall of Mirrors it
is you can't yeah you can't use a sick
brain to think your way out of having a
sick brain it's like trying to buy your
own teeth or trying to touch your right
elbow with your right index finger you
can't do it and when and when you're in
that state you don't know that your
brain is sick no you don't no you don't
and this is why things like things that
I'd learned earlier things like writing
things down things like talking to
people
observing meditating I had really helped
now look
I still have hard days I had a hard day
today I rode a bicycle here because I
needed to move my body a bit to to kind
of down regulate a bit from earlier in
the day like it's still hard it's not
it's not everything's not [__] roses
and I'm a punish to live with sometimes
because I can get very very focused very
focused to the point where
you might have moved on from a topic but
I'm still talking about three sentences
ago and I can't let it go and it's
really hard to speak with me sometimes
and that's really tough on the people
that I love and I I struggle with what I
put them through sometimes
yeah I've noticed and talking to you
sometimes your brain moves so quickly
that that we'll be talking about
something but then you'll throw a couple
other things in there and then I'm I'm
like wait what what is happening right
now I'm not quite sure sorry yeah and
it's not no it you know I think in this
conversation you've been very linear
but I've noticed it like just socially a
little bit it can't happen it's just
like it's not like there's nothing
negative about that it's just uh
something that I've noticed it happens
yeah it
like the meds that I'm one now they tend
to wear off towards the end of the day
and so evenings can be a bit difficult
um
because I can get back into those things
um but look that's all you know
when the when when I'm medicated it
works and it's okay you know but it's
still it's look it's like you know when
I first got sober I had to I I had the
thing that people may not understand
about drinking is that people all
understand that it affects your memory
right but that of memory affecting the
the effect of the memory also affects
your ability to learn and feel the
pain and damage emotionally that you've
caused so you don't connect this
horrible feeling in your body with your
own actions and so ultimately I started
drinking to black out at 14. so here I
am suddenly I'm 36 with the emotional
ability of a 14 year old trying to get
through life and I had to learn all that
[__] I had to really literally learn it
like reading books about how to do it
because I had no idea and similarly you
know I have to learn how to do other
stuff that people have figured out when
they were six and that's hard yeah when
you're 49 but I am here to learn and I'm
here to grow and I'm here to like I know
I'm getting it wrong I know I get
probably get it wrong more than I'd like
but I'm not here to pretend that life's
[__] amazing and Rosy it's not it's
hard
but it's also you know it's worth it's
worth it it's worth trying because who I
get to be because of the trying is worth
it
um
and look I honestly I would not
we've talked a lot about this but we
haven't talked about how incredible
Audrey was in all this so again I met
the woman is now my wife when I was
going through all of this [__] through
all of it and I remember speaking to her
just telling her about you know like
all these are completely deluded things
that are going on and I'm like you know
the Pacific Islands getting washed away
and entire cultures are getting
destroyed and you know it's like as real
as real could be to me
and she just she could see that I wasn't
really
really bad and she just said look if it
does come to that
I'll be with you and it'll be okay
and that was for the first time in years
that I believed it might end up in a
different way to how I've been convinced
that it would end up
and she you know it was like I was in it
they used to have these dance parties
here in marrickville Bowls Club Black
Market I don't know if I remember
everything but they used to cover the
mirrors in black plastic right and it
was like someone had taken a pin because
the parties would go all day uh from the
night before and they're like I just
want to take in a pin and pop through
the black plastic and there was just
this tiny little pinprick of light
because I'd been in that Darkness for so
long and when she said that to me I was
like oh
oh all right so all the things that I'm
thinking could happen and
I could be holding her hand at the same
time
oh
and that that was the thing that changed
everything like that that woman
absolutely saved my life there's no
question no question I'm very lucky
because of that
um because it was I needed someone it's
it's worth it to be a better person for
them I was living alone before I met
them when you live alone you don't have
to you're not accountable to anyone you
can be a bastard and you know you put
your social face on and whatever and
that's it but then you're alone
fun
um so yeah you also don't have anyone to
give you that feedback and
accountability on your behavior yeah in
real time absolutely yeah yeah and
that's the you know that's really
that's the thing I suddenly had these
two incredible people who I was I
couldn't help but be so completely
hopelessly in love with her and
um just so much
eternal love that just showed up out of
nowhere for G she was 11.
he's 19 now
you know and I didn't know what to do
with this thing because I'm a selfish
prick you know and suddenly he says I'm
no longer number one [__] hell you
know it was all it all that's it that
was like okay this is what I have to do
this and now you have a son now yeah
Wolfie in that so how does that change
how you think about all of this and keep
you on track and
um
it's it's very I guess it's very kind of
twofold you know part of it
is
I
try to communicate whenever I can as
much as I can with
about how much work needs to get done
because eventually everyone's going to
get it you know eventually everyone's
going to get how much work needs to get
done and the work will get done it'll
just be way harder like we don't have to
change the diet after the heart attack
we could eat better now and not even
having a heart attack or even just get a
really kind of nasty scare which is
probably what we're having right now
we're having a nasty climate scare all
right but let's not go through the heart
attack
um but you know humans humans we come we
kind of wait for that unfortunately it's
[__] man I know it's terrible it's
terrible so on one hand it's like well
but then again I don't know anything I
don't know everything I I rode a bicycle
here I could get taken out of the way
home all right
and so all I have is this day all I have
is this moment literally all we have is
now as Wayne coin would say like this is
it
and so when I'm you know every day with
it's very in you know it's really easy
and very obvious when they're little
because they change so much so fast but
like she's a new kid every six weeks she
just you know it's subtly different but
she's very you know she changes so often
she still grows and changes and thinks
about things and she's a very powerful
woman and just try to be as present as I
can and witness to it and
you know
that you only have to do today you know
I look sometimes I gotta
I've got 13 years the other day
and I said I put a thing on my phone
because I kind of stopped Counting
and I put up on my phone I was like
[__] hell
and they say oh it's a day at a time but
honestly like some days it was five
minutes at a time
but you only have to do it for five more
minutes
and just trust that you'll be able to
cope in five minutes from now because
you will
and
so thinking about you asked about what's
going to happen you know looking how do
I think about everything
look I just trust that whatever happens
that I'll be able to cope
whatever shows up I'll be able to cope
it's not like some giant cataclysm is
going to happen and I'll suddenly forget
how you have you have that that muscle
memory I mean you've endured a lot and
so you know that you're able and capable
of like you know getting through
difficult situations I have a lot of
empathy for people who haven't been
through that climate thing I think it's
really um it's really important I think
to be with the reality of it and
sit down and really have a look all
right because during we had some
bushfires here the black summer we
called it yeah I was here yeah it was
and that was going on devastating all
right and people are texting me every
day because I read the book and stuff
like are you okay are you okay I'm like
mate I saw this when it wasn't there for
the years like I'd close my eyes and it
would be there like I
I've been through what you're going
through right now because suddenly for a
lot of people that in my life it was oh
oh [__] like yes yes you I get it so I
have a lot of empathy for people who
haven't been through that and people who
are resisting that but it's really
important I think a lot of the delilism
that we see around climate stuff is
trying to avoid that pain all right when
you start talking about you know climate
change people think oh it's you know
seawater or whatever it's like mate it's
food security it's water coming out of
your TAP it's immigration it's National
Security it's everything
but the thing is because it's everything
it means everything's a solution there's
everywhere to get into action because
being an action is a sense of agency and
being an action is freedom from the pain
that you're in the only way out of the
Flames is through pun intended the only
way out of the Flames is through you
just have to keep moving it just doesn't
matter picks pick a spot go in one
direction do that
and then at least you're moving and that
can give you what you need to get to bed
that night going well what can I control
I can control it you know do what I can
do the next right thing I got really
lucky to get all the skills that I got
from getting sober really helped me in
this part on on the mental health stuff
though yeah in your journey you know
with the with the book
um and the live events that you do and
the amount of time that you spend
talking about this kind of stuff behind
a microphone
um you must have a sense of of the
impact that it's making you must have
you know men people coming up to you
like it's a Lifeline for a lot of people
yeah there aren't that many people who
are talking about mental health in its
most severe form in the way that in the
way that you do yeah like once once
again I got very lucky and I got to come
off the antipsychotics some people don't
and I'm very very lucky because of that
but I think I'm you know if I ask you
know what is complex mental illness look
like or what does psychosis look like
people might think oh it's the guy on
the buses shouting and stuff that I
can't see it can be you know it could be
you know you in a finely tailored yeah
that's it but that's what it is so it
shows up in unlikely forms as well one
in five one in five Australians is
effective by complex mental illness all
right and that could be person suffering
a bit like for every person that has
been diagnosed five people are affected
by it so
um when you look at those stats
it's like which means there's a lot of
people walking around undiagnosed oh no
diagnosed but they're just not talking
oh I see and they're managing it and you
asked earlier about
I got really lucky with my workplace
because I'm I know I'm a high value
employee and I was really honest with my
boss and said like mate this is what's
going on just so you know this is why
I'm a bit strange this is what's
happening this is the doctors I'm seeing
these are the meds I'm taking this is
the exercise I'm doing this is the
mediums and go to and all these things
mean that I'll still be able and I
really need to keep coming to work
because giving me something to do it's
like when someone gets injured at work
you want to get them back as quick as
possible because that's a huge part of
them getting better and having an agent
a reason to get out of bed and a reason
to go to work is it's a really important
thing in getting healthy and my boss
Stephen amazing he just said well what
do you need from us and like because at
one in one breath I told it I disclosed
and I wouldn't recommend I'm don't
saying you should disclose like only if
you're really comfortable and you feel
you're gonna be okay
because in one breath I told him what
was going on but I also told him how I
was managing it and told him that I was
taking responsibility for it and
then that made it not his problem to fix
and I think that's a really important
thing like you can you know it can
happen to you or it can happen for you
you know you can either let that let it
have you or you can have it you know
it's really it's really that's all it is
um and if you if you take responsibility
for it then you have a bit more a bit
more sense that you're not being sort of
flight around so much it still comes and
grabs me sometimes and kind of [__] up
my day
um as I did today but it it's if I know
that you know well I'm doing what I can
with what I have and it might not be
that you know and and how how is all of
this informed your relationship with
your career
as somebody who you know used to have
that kind of [__] mentality don't you
know who I think I am yeah exactly oh
that's exactly what it was yeah
so now you know
being really successful and being on
these really popular television shows
and being somebody who's gonna get
recognized on the street and all of that
like how does that
influence like you know where does the
ambition sit how have you right-sized
yourself and and and formed like a
healthier relationship with all with all
that it it came from changing why I
showed up at work and you know I said
I'll you know
how do you be a worker among workers
when you're the [__] guy on the Telly
you know how do you do that how do you
have a head of humility around that and
what I tried to do was try to just be
the most professional what I try to do
is like how can I make everyone else's
day at work the easiest that I can make
it so I spent a long time probably not
making it very easy so how can I make it
the audio person's easiest day at work
that camera person that camera person
this person how can I make their day the
easiest Day by being on time by being
completely prepared by being as
professional as it possibly can be by
you know asking them about their day you
know being you know getting in and out
getting it done all right
and that in turn makes me very good at
what I do
because that's what I want to do it for
all right
there was a time when I did it because I
wanted to have you know the rating
success and all that [__] and we did you
know Australia very risk at first when
it comes to TV so we did the mask singer
in Australia as well and I host that I'm
very lucky to it's a [__] super fun
show but there was a big it was a hit
the first season was a hit and people
are texting and quietly go hey
congratulations congratulations I'm like
I didn't want to say to them but I
appreciate you congratulating me but
it's not like we don't work as hard on
the ones that don't work we work just as
hard this power why it was successful
has nothing to do with me
um all I can do is
show up do it as best I can
try to push myself try to learn
something try to make other people stay
good
and then go home
and that's the job I I don't do
marketing I don't do promos I don't cut
I have no idea what the other Network's
gonna program against me I have no no
idea I can't attach very different from
podcasting right to do the whole thing
all of it oh yeah yeah and network
television there's whole departments
yeah in charge of all that kind of stuff
that you just you say you do your bit
and then you leave and go home but I
can't I used to I would definitely get
tied into the outcome and I know you've
spoken about this like you know and I've
heard you talk about this with people
who've done you know extraordinary
athletic things it's not like the gold
medal that you hold at the end is the
prize who you became to hold the gold
medal is the prize
and that's why you do it it's not it's
not like everything's gonna be fine when
I hold this thing no that's that's not
it who you become to hold this thing
that's it and
we've got to kind of asked backwards
around that with success in our in our
society I think you know this amount of
money at the end of the year you've made
it have you
because I've had that amount of money
and it just you know it swiftly went
away trust me but it didn't make it
didn't make everything awesome it didn't
don't worry it all went away because you
know internet gambling and okay it's all
gone gone all right
yeah it but it's it's who you become
because of it and that's the day-to-day
stuff you know because ultimately that's
all that's all there is and who would
you say that you've become
oh man
I'm trying to I don't know rich
I'm just I'm
I just
I don't know mate I don't know how to
answer that question I don't know how to
answer that question I I just every step
I take away from the person I was before
I stopped drinking and using is is a
good place to be
I think if any of us can try to
transcend the patterns of behavior that
haven't served us and write new ones
then we have done the universe's service
by not allowing those kind of things to
carry for forward any further and that
might be you know
some of the racist Granddad or someone's
homophobic mom or whatever like that can
stop with you you can choose that or
not that I had a racist Granddad or a
homophob but you you can choose to you
can choose to stop that so identifying
the parts of who I am that don't serve
me and going do I really need that
can I let go of that can I do something
else like it's a bit hard because I can
get a bit robotic in my thinking
sometimes so it can be hard to get the
new versions of things in but it takes
time but it eventually works and if I
can just do that then
I'm all right and as far as everything
else mate
fit fit fit fit dead
that's it I'm Mark I'm there's no bypass
for me I am I like how you distilled it
down but I do I do think it's worth
noting that piece around
interrupting the
intergenerational uh transfer uh
um hereditary or inherited traumas and
behavior patterns that cause havoc and
it could be from an ex-relationship
and you become very present with that
when you become a parent obviously and
you're looking at your young child and
you and you're thinking about how you
were raised or what your grandparents
endured and you realize that you can be
a stop Gap like you can arrest whatever
thing that runs in the background on
autopilot yeah
um you have the agency to interrupt and
and perhaps make it you know the last
the last stop on that line right so that
Wolfie you know isn't isn't like
intuiting that and passing and like
exuding that and then passing it on the
worst thing the worst thing about
parenting it's not the sleep it's not
the you know being tired all the time or
being crappy to each other that's not it
they don't do what you tell them but
they do what you show them that is the
worst part because you see some [__] in
them and go you move oh you got that
from me [__] and then you have to and
that's the clue as to what you need to
look at yeah that thing yeah
sorry yeah and you have to sort that
[__] out because and I think stuff like
that is how another way that we can get
a little closer to the kind of like
society-wide change we're going to need
to get us out of this Mass
like that kind of fear of change this
idea that no once and we always did it
let's say we're always going to have to
do it no no
you know we have the choice to to help
our children become
more open to change and more open to new
ideas we have that ability
and that's really really important
because when it starts with us and that
starts in the home it bloody does mate
yeah it really does
um I think that's a good place to put a
pen in that for today my friend bringing
it around the corner
um I love you buddy uh you know the the
journey that you've been on is just it's
it's it's [__] unbelievable dude and
the the level of vulnerability and
courage uh that you've demonstrated to
weather this and come to the other side
and be in a place where you can talk
about it you know comfortably is an
incredible service I I thank you so much
mate for having me and like don't
underestimate the role that you and
Julie and your family have played
because
I don't know like I don't think you
lived it you never lived in another
country did you
okay I was a long way a long way from
home a long way from my family a long
way from my friends and to be able to
like you felt it last night when you're
at our place to go oh a family ah it's
not my family ah
I could leave it then go warm delicious
food nice dogs yeah
rattlesnakes Bay nice dogs you know
that is unbelievable it's a Lifeboat on
the other side of the planet you know it
really is and knowing you know I
sometimes just ride past your house
not in a weird way just to go I saw my
friends live you know just ride past the
house just well you you always have a
have a home at our home and we didn't
even get to the part about
the importance of of kind of fitness and
physical activity as part of the mental
health Journey like we spent a lot of
time on the bike together and the bike
as a tool for you know kind of
contending with demons and I'll get them
to the other side there's a huge part of
a huge part of me feeling better that
involves and I believe now because I
listen to a man whose career you [__]
jump-started uh Andrew there's a lot of
references to people but he sure doesn't
reference you enough
um I love him I'll listen to him every
week
um it talks about the catecholam it
talks about dopamine norepinephrine um
serotonin now all these things exist
within my body and when my body was not
well I needed to take meds to help
stimulate the production of those things
but these things exist in my body though
there's things I need to do to release
them into my body and that we're
designed to move we're designed to lift
we're designed to be active we're
designed to move through space we're
supposed to be out and about getting our
food walking around doing things
interacting with other human beings all
of these things all of these hormones
give my body what it needs to shift mood
States throughout the day and if I don't
have enough of those that can be a
problem I can get quite stuck
but I don't know you can you talk about
it and Audrey certainly does to me she's
like I swing some kettlebells mate go
get on your bike just yeah go and I
understand that you know I I sometimes
I've got a Ergo now I've got a rowing
machine and it's dude it's great 25
minutes so I can get whatever
you can use that anxiety I can use that
energy that has been released in my body
there's a huge chunk of adrenaline it's
like I don't need no pre-workout hit me
give me some deadlifts sure can I
remember like during some of your harder
periods where you were like you were
just out on the bike for hours like the
whole day yes right and I was like I
know what that guy oh I know what that's
about oh yeah it's Wednesday and you
call me where are you I'm here it's like
that's 30 miles from your house yes it
is
Upper Mountain but that's that's what I
needed to do on that day to stay to stay
okay because that's a sense of agency
there's a great sense of I'm here under
my own power I have some control I have
some ability to move myself not everyone
can do that I'm very lucky that I could
and just the sense of mental space that
you get and the kind of active
meditative effect of of being in a
elevated heart rate and connecting with
your breath that allows you to problem
solve or make you know try to make sense
of yeah your situation and what you're
trying to work through in a way that
doesn't happen when you're at home on
the couch no and it's not like I sit
there and I'm working through it like a
math problem no just be like Ronnie
ain't going like oh seagull it happens
in the unconscious part of your brain
while you're doing that yeah and then
just pops because you're not looking at
it directly yeah it pops up and you go
oh there it is and there's never a
problem that I went I took on a run that
I didn't come back with a solution with
never not once but I I gotta say that
this is the tricky part about dosage is
increasing I got that feeling from just
walking around my block when I was super
unfit the problem is now is like to get
that again like here you go I push
myself wow I've got a heart rate I've
got a heart rate strap now and you know
because the Med's online I've got to be
careful with my blood pressure and stuff
like that so I send them some regular
updates to my man and my psychiatrist
he's always like damn like yeah I know
like I just when I got my leg done
um I'm in the thing the alarm kept going
off because I thought it was bradycardic
because it's like [__] 50 beats a
minute 49 basement like proper like
because I've just been going in the
first surgery I went in as fit as I
possibly could be back in 2020 I went in
so fit they're like are you okay okay
I'm fine but like you know I know that
I don't have to sustain that kind of
heart rate when I'm really like doing
intervals like really hard but I know
you only have to be there for a little
bit you know minute off minute on for a
little while and that's enough just the
fire hoses your brain down major State
change oh man like you try to be angry
or upset or scared after all that [__]
floods your brain and that's for free
you know that's for free you can get
that doing burpees
and not enough people know that you know
it's amazing yeah man all right well we
gotta get out of here but let's close it
down with with uh maybe a final thought
for uh he or she who's still suffering
like I'm just imagining somebody who's
watching us or listening who's thinking
you know maybe I have some stuff I need
to look at
um ushers you know kicking up some stuff
it feels a little uncomfortable right
now I don't know where to direct that
energy like do you have resources that
you can direct people towards or you
know a thought that you could share to
help you know direct or guide that
person who's dancing around the outer
edges of of seeking help well I would
say look I I play a lot of Poker like
one of the things I'm really lucky for
is I play a poker game every Wednesday
and I'll be playing a poker game since
2003 so it's the same group of 10 12
guys so I've got these guys in my life
and so uh and I have we've been through
a lot together and there's a there's a
person who shows up poker table who
doesn't know how to play very well and
everyone spots them and they kind of
play them and they basically treat them
like a human ATM and that person's
called the fish and there's this phrase
going if you can't spot the fish at the
table it's you
and so if you're going through life and
you're like
everyone [__] wasn't them do what I
say what's going on why does everyone's
everyone's the [__]
might be you and just that's okay it's
okay you are where you are with the the
skills and the tools that you've got
that's fine there's more skills and
tools and ways to deal you just need to
go ask someone to show you and that's
fine it's okay there's no shame in
figuring out better ways to do things if
you're going through life and everything
is
kind of it's constantly a Rocky [__]
Road
it's okay you're going in the direction
you want to go to but maybe maybe you
want to get a better set of tires maybe
you want to get a bit of suspension
maybe you need a bit of co-pilot like
there's plenty of things that you can
get on board
there's no need to gut through it you're
not alone and there's plenty of help
plenty of help and look I know I live in
this incredible country with this
amazing Healthcare System but there's
just psycho education alone
learn about cognitive distortions learn
about what happens when your body's
captured by anxiety learn the difference
between an amygdala hijack and um what's
the other one there's a negative one
there's a camera what it was learn like
when you're in anxiety learn what your
amygdala does to your body understand
that you know if you're in a meeting and
everyone's being an [__] and your
hands are shaking you've shouted the
last three things you've said
oh I'm in fighter flight right
right someone said something
that has nothing to do with this
situation but it has triggered a
response from long time ago and I should
probably not have to claw and buy my way
out of this room I might just take a bit
of a breath here you know understand
that stuff and and and just kind of just
learn and that you know what's amazing
is like yeah YouTube can convince you
some pretty wrong [__] but it's also a
huge amount of like really clever
um go for people who are actual doctors
go for people who are from universities
uh there's some really clever psycho
education out there just just learning
what it is naming it to tame it is a
really important thing cognitive
cognitive distortions is a really
powerful like learning what the big
cognitive distortions are learning what
anxiety is learning what your prefrontal
cortex does you know learning how to
down regulate you can learn how to you
know just you can do a thing called
polyvagal breathing which is really easy
it's just three and six out I do that in
meetings all the time I do that on air
no one knows I'm doing it what am I
doing I'm stimulating my vagus nerve
like tricking my body into its
relaxation response and it's super easy
to do a four in eight out don't do any
more than that if you're standing up
like we're driving I guess there's so
many things you can do yeah no that's
great I mean I would I would Echo all of
that but supplement it with this idea of
not trying to like we were talking about
earlier solve it in the confines of your
mind quietly no instead raise your hand
and let people in find somebody you
trust it could be a friend it could be a
colleague it could be a professional but
develop the habit of
being open with somebody who can help
guide you like if you use all of these
things thrive in the darkness and in
isolation yeah and I think when you're
in that
situation there's a there's shame
attached to it which makes you want to
kind of deal with it privately yeah it
makes it worse and all that's going to
do is
prolong it and exacerbate it yeah if if
you know you
if I run my bicycle here and if I got
here and you know I'd Fallen really
badly and I'd had a mad double spiral
fracture in my forearm my hand was
hanging down like that like dude we're
gonna get you to a [__] doctor no no
she'll be right mate you'd think I was
[__] crazy all right but people do
that every day when it comes to Mental
Health
get to a Goddamn doctor and fast because
these things don't get better they get
worse as I've spoken about today because
I wasn't treating it and it was getting
worse and worse and worse and worse and
worse and eventually it just it nearly
killed me
um but there's so much help and
there's a huge amount of power that
comes from taking control and taking
control is to ask for help and that's
that's that's really powerful
particularly with men men like to be in
charge well be in charge pick up the
phone Power go do something about it and
like if you're I use automotive
analogies because they work you know if
there's this this side this this idea
that it's weakness to do that but if
it's weakness to do that then why are
you so scared to do it yeah like so I'm
in I'm in the I'm in the car and I'm
flying down the freeway taking my entire
family on holiday right and um the front
left tire blows out
all right do I pull over
what do I go no I'm gonna keep going
like I'm doing 110 K's an hour and
everyone I love is in this vehicle and
now it's super dangerous like and if I
then pull over and refuse if I don't
have the tools to fix the car what what
am I going to do you know
mate of course you're going to call the
roadside assistance of course you're
going to pull the car over it's the same
with your brain if you find yourself
like getting really rigid in your
thinking and you find yourself kind of
getting cranky all the time or just
crying or wanting to vomit out of
nowhere that happened to me as well like
when I was in lockdown in Melbourne I'm
just like out of nowhere I just want to
dispute just like like I've been
drinking tequila kind of on I was like
that's not good it was just a signal
going I was on the phone of my doctor
like that because I know that happens
about two weeks before the other [__]
starts so being on top of that kind of
stuff like get some tools you'd pull a
car over like if you don't have that
[__] get learn how to do it get some
tools and get your family there safely
because you're that's ultimately who's
going to get hurt if you don't look
after things
maybe we'll get some links and some
other resources we can uh fill the show
notes out with oh please yeah people
with yeah some
places they can go and some phone
numbers they can call it started Susan
David and go from there there you go
start a season that's right right she is
amazing the business uncomfortable
feelings at the price of admission to a
meaningful life be with that and that is
half a work done right on me all right
to be continued all right love you man
thank you yeah we're done for today I
love you dude I love you all right no I
was like really you're gonna have me
back plants and go see Usher's live new
NT n n or whatever it is if you're in
Australia I don't even know what it's
it's like not the new nighttime
nighttime News Network National Nightly
News there you go yeah it's not a it's
not a fake news show it's a fake news
show
because the news is a product all right
a product like anything else and
depending on how exactly the fact is
told to you uh you can either think wow
those people really need our help and we
should look after them because there's a
country who look after each other and we
think everyone deserves a fair go or if
you read it in another Outlet you go
[__] off wherefore this fear goes only
for white people
but that's what happens here in our
country and we I think the way that
particularly I think the way the news
media in our country has been behaving
really needs to be able to account and
um and you're the man to do it dude I
you know putting my entire network
career at risk every night I promise you
all right cheers love you man